are you out of your mind here's the
debate
you're upset
conversation's not quite very well
she was way more experienced anyways
folks i believe we're we're are we live
or no yes sir you missed a conversation
with a very good friend of adam anyway
mutual friends episode 162 today with uh
governor candidate of uh
of uh florida yes uh nikki freed and the
13. is it the 13th or the 12th the 12th
uh agriculture commissioner uh in the
state of florida and she's been that
since 2019 and we got a lot of things to
get into today so thank you so much for
making the time to come out uh uh for
the sake of timing i think we got 60
minutes together we got one hour so
let's just get right into it one of the
questions that's been really you know
weighing on me for a while is
there's a lot of people in florida who
are
you know fans of florida with what's
going on with florida but i haven't met
anybody that admires and loves the
sentence as much as you
why is that
what's the reasoning why you love the
governor so much like i'm really curious
where should we we don't have we're only
an hour right i'm actually curious why
do you love this man so much you know
it's interesting you know when we first
got elected uh all four of us on the
cabinet so for those who don't know the
cabinet consists of the governor uh the
chief financial officer the attorney
general and the commission of
agriculture and i was actually really
hopeful you know all four of us were
under the age of 50 all had younger
families and i really was like okay
great maybe there's an opportunity for
us to show the rest the country what
bipartisan support looks like we had a
lot of mutual friends i had known the
attorney general since our time in
undergrad and law school knew the cfo
from when he was the legislature ashley
right ashley you know was that jimmy
patroness as well as cfo yeah so i had
known them all for i was like okay we're
gonna we're gonna do this we're gonna do
some good stuff together
and i was really wrong i'm not wrong a
lot in my life but but this was this was
a big one and unfortunately uh you know
starting really kind of towards the
latter part of 2019 he just was coming
in there there was violations of
sunshine there was just not working with
everybody and the biggest thing started
really in 2020 when he tried to come in
and take my office of energy which falls
underneath the commissioner and we had
done some really really great things
under there and i was like why why wha
what's the point we're doing good stuff
and it came down to power and that's
when i realized this guy is no good that
he cares about one thing and one thing
only and that's how to get more power
and every decision that he's made since
then uh is how to consolidate power
behind the governor i mean look what he
did to legislature this past week that
he made the senate president and the
speaker of the house stand next to him
as he vetoed 3.1 billion dollars and
laughed at them
that's not who a governor is supposed to
be and i've watched him become a
dictator and really try to consolidate
this power marginalize people
yell at our kids
all for his goal of powering to get to
the white house okay so now you say that
about him but tell us uh what are you
running on so the audience also knows
what uh you're for yep absolutely and
that's more important more important to
know what the people are running for so
look we'll get into both of them but i
just want to make sure they also know
what you're for so i have been our
elected statewide democrat uh for three
and a half years and i have been every
single day fighting for the people of
our state making sure that everybody's
got to see the table making sure that
you know people that have been
marginalized before
know that there's someone fighting for
them and today we have a real serious
problem in our state that we have seen
that republicans unfortunately and my
dad's a republican so i want to also be
very clear i grew up and as you were
talking about before on air that there's
a you know communism versus imperialism
in your household my dad is a die-hard
republican when i was doing soup
kitchens and habitat for humanity in
miami growing up he was getting me nra
t-shirts so we are you know that's kind
of the household that i grew up what was
your mom she is a die-hard democrat she
was a teacher for 25 years and they're
still together oh no no no
that's not a good case example for
america there nikki
how long were they married for 25 years
wow
that's a long time a long time sometimes
that 25 years is simply until the kids
turn 18. that's what they're waiting for
yeah but it's 14.
okay there you go now we can't wait in
four more years sorry i was 12. they got
divorced twice my parents in in 20 years
they married each other divorced married
each other divorced in 20 years wow
similar story please continue so so i
was watching all of this and at the end
of the day that's not what government's
supposed to be government is supposed to
be able to bring people together inspire
people making sure that everybody's got
economic opportunities get that american
dream of home ownership and living here
and government's staying out of the way
you know i've always again from my dad
was hot about what public republicans
are supposed to be about less government
less taxes less spending local control
free market the republicans of today
don't stand for any of that and seeing
again the government intrusion every
single day where i'm somebody i came in
i created the hemp program here in the
state of florida so first time we
created a new industry in our state and
i created an open market that living
anybody who wants to cultivate to
manufacture to distribute
has an equal opportunity to succeed so i
look at things of how do i make people's
lives better not how do i go after
people how to make lives better and
unfortunately for you know what the
republicans have been doing for the last
you know a couple of years is dividing
us and so i come to the table said look
there's a better way to lead there's a
way to make sure that the people are are
the first priority making sure we're not
taking away people's rights to vote and
taking away people's rights to protest
and going after communities and most
importantly we have an economic disaster
happening in our state that people can't
afford to live here we become the number
one unaffordability we have surpassed
california and new york
that's been underneath these republican
leaders and so i say look at the end of
the day i want to come in i want to give
people an opportunity for that american
dream and to make sure that we're
creating policies that are going to give
opportunities awesome
have you lived in different states or no
born and raised in florida born and
raised here okay so do you like good
food because i like really good food i
do like you like good food so how do you
judge a good restaurant
i judge a good restaurant first of all
by the service okay um but two i love i
love spices and i love the ingredients
that go into things and and having a
different flair on you know you can go
to a chinese restaurant at a mexican
restaurant in a cuban restaurant but i
love when they do like a spin
on the traditional types of food because
it's a it's a new experience and i what
do they call that there's a name for
that right the
is it a fusion or it's like you know
when they mix it to exactly latin fusion
yeah every restaurant i mean one of my
favorite restaurants in vegas is chino
poblano and it's like mexican food plus
chinese i was like i've never been to a
chinese place where do you see this
place wait do you see this so you like
spices you like mix you like fusion what
else
well that's i think that is a big part
of it is making sure that you've got
this experience because people go out
for food and if you're going out it's
not just the food you're going out for
the experience have you ever gone to a
restaurant for the first time and then
walked out 30 seconds into it
have you gone to a restaurant you're
walking you're like you know uh
i'm looking at yelp
let's go let's go check this place out
okay you go to this place and i was like
guys
we got to get out of here
so how do we judge it though that's
based on what that's based on no one's
there during lunch yeah right so you
judge a restaurant many times based on
if you're the only customer there at a
restaurant during you know prime time
there is something wrong with this
restaurant right okay i feel like you're
going somewhere with you i want to
i want to i want to i want to take what
you're saying and say okay fine
let's listen to
what florida is doing wrong and what's
going on over here and you know all this
other stuff how terrible the state has
been under desantis and all this stuff
this okay sounds good from 2020 if you
go till 2022 today i lived in l.a 20
some years i lived in dallas five years
i was in the army so i lived all over
the place and i've been here for a
little over a year and a half
since the guys taken office no matter
how much they've tried to trash this guy
everybody keeps moving here this place
is busy people are coming here from east
coast from new york from baltimore from
dc from chicago from l.a from from all
over the place they're coming here
california is losing people their first
net negative since 1851 new york's
losing people no matter what they say
they're losing people this place flipped
from purple to red so for someone that
just maybe a data person they may say
nikki it's great that you have those
bullet points that you go through with
the messaging you're saying but the data
simply doesn't back you up the data says
they're doing a great job in florida
what do you say to those people well
first of all you kind of look at florida
for a couple of reasons people don't
come here because of desantis that that
i did
did you i did and i'll tell you why in a
little bit i want you to finish but i
did um so but they come here because the
beautiful weather
because of our beaches um because of the
diversity of our state they come here
because there's no income tax
um and so all those things and during
the pandemic there there was a influx
here to the state absolutely but the
problem is now that the people are here
we have no infrastructure there is no
planning of exactly how we're going to
expand out our state i mean look look at
today we have tremendous amount of rain
now born and raised here in miami this
is not a storm this is this is a rain
we're used to this this is
a saturday yeah but i was talking to the
mayor earlier today and some of our city
and county commissioners and there's
flooding everywhere
there's flooding everywhere and there's
cars being abandoned and and there's no
infrastructure there's no money there's
been no conversation about how to make
sure when all these people are moving
into our state how we're taking care of
the people that are actually living i
get that but so so that to me then
becomes
step three but step one is you know hey
we're attracting all this talent if you
have a company that you're recruiting a
lot of high best
engineers i want to come to you're doing
something right then all of a sudden you
get
3 000 new employees that are coming to
your company now you're like listen guys
we need 16 hr people we need software we
need this we need that we need coaching
we need you know we need all this stuff
but step number one is why do we get
three thousand engineers because when
you said something like uh people are
now moving to florida for desantis well
then perfect so let me flip it on you
why are people leaving a beautiful state
like california are they leaving because
of the weather is so bad are they
leaving because the beach is so bad i
was just in l.a last week the weather is
sick there's so many reasons to stay in
california people left california
because of newsome and many people came
to florida because of desantis the nba i
remember when nba first when the covet
first started everybody was talking
about
florida i cannot believe what they were
that at the breakers we weren't living
here yet they're not doing this they're
not doing that and then the nba black
lives matter awesome what are you guys
doing your playoffs florida wait what
orlando state you bashed
you can only do your playoffs in one
state so
again going back to it i know you're
saying infrastructure but wouldn't you
agree like at a time like this when
you're running the guy
has done so many things right where a
lot of people across the country or
families they have kids they're sitting
there saying at least this guy's got
backbone because if his policies were
bad why would people move to florida it
wouldn't just be the weather the guy's
done a lot of good policies and i feel
like i feel whether you guys have some
areas you agree with or not of course
he's going to say some stuff that he
says about you when somebody asked him
on a what was it when he was doing the
town hall meeting she's just doing what
she's doing on social media he made the
comments about you i'm sure you saw that
and you made comments about him and i
know you know the comments because
you've talked about we'll get into that
here in a minute as well but wouldn't
you give him a little bit of credit of
what what he's done in florida last
couple of years
look you know i have said very clearly
you know when covet hit
is covet hit and i had actually called
on him to close on the state early
because i knew that if we closed down
the state early that we would be able to
get open earlier and that we had able to
save lives no he he sat down and didn't
do no that wouldn't happen though nikki
i gotta i gotta just jump in on that let
me just let me just jump in on this for
one second because i i very much
appreciate your perspective but i am
that person that fled new york city i
love my city i love new york city i was
there my whole life the last 20 years
i did come here
for because of desantis i was looking at
different states i was looking at states
that were fighting for people's
individual freedoms i was i have a
two-year-old i was very very bogged down
in new york city by not just the crime
by the fact that the police force felt
unsupported but by the mandates and by
the restrictions and the lockdowns and i
felt like so much of that stuff was
being thrown out there to try to control
people and there wasn't science that
backed any of those policies and what
you saw here
at first i looked from afar but what you
saw here was a guy who and i'm not a
republican i'm an independent and i'm
not someone who has a loyalty to
politicians if desantis does something i
don't like i'll be the first person to
to call him out on that but i saw a guy
who kept the state open and he wasn't
when the masks came down he was asking
questions like do we want to enforce
these policies where is the data to back
this up
when the vaccine mandates came down he
wasn't afraid to say hold on a second
i'm not getting in the way of people's
individual relationships with their
doctors that's not my job if you want to
get vaccinated great if you don't want
to get vaccinated that's up to you so i
saw a guy that wasn't afraid at a very
difficult moment in history to say
i'm going to stand up for people's
individual freedoms so when when i hear
things like you know you said he was an
authoritarian and it sounded to me
truthfully like you had a lot of
personality issues with him maybe maybe
you guys just don't get along in the
same way that a lot of people had
personality issues with donald trump and
felt like you know character wise maybe
he wasn't the guy for the job or the way
he approached the public wasn't the
right guy for the job but honestly
authoritarian or dictator that's the
furthest thing i think of when i think
of descendants because he was fighting
against those policies you want to talk
to an authoritarian talk to bill de
blasio talk to gavin newsom talk to
people who were telling people you need
to do this or else desantis wasn't doing
that he's not doing that he's doing on
every other policy everywhere everywhere
where is it that you see that i'm
curious and i'm curious everything else
from taking power away from the
legislature every single step of the way
what he did with the maps that was
taking power away from the legislature
trying to take power away from the
cabinet from from my own position
everything he's done to
really strip a lot of power going after
the school boards you know when you talk
about individual freedoms every
individual school board was trying to
make up the decisions of what was best
for their own communities and not only
did he go after the school board members
he then threatened how was he going
after the school board members like what
saying what well first of all he was
going to remove superintendents if they
had actually done mass mandates he was
looking to withhold dollars from each of
the school boards who actually had a
mass mandate in place he actually was
holding back money from our school
districts that were done but was he
preventing people who wanted to wear
masks in those schools from wearing
masks what he was doing was no it was he
though was he if you wanted to wear a
mask till kingdom come for the next was
he saying don't wear a mask or was he
saying if you don't want to wear a mask
you shouldn't be mandated to because
this is not that first that's not what
he did that's not what he did what he
did was he shamed people for wearing
masks he made them feel you're stupid he
actually yelled at our kids who did wear
masks and yells and take that damn thing
off your face
that is not what a governor is supposed
to do a governor if he really truly
cared about freedom he should have let
those kids be them whoever they want
because then that was going their kids
their parents asked them to do that or
they had a conversation look what he's
doing on abortion rights talking about
you just had talked about you shouldn't
be getting in between between a doctor
and a personal freedom decision he just
went after it that's a little bit
different though but it well that's in
your portion's a little bit different
because it involves a third person
though you have to acknowledge that
right no i mean
listen i support exceptions for for rape
incest life of the mother we can have
that debate all day long about abortion
but
the reality is that there is another
person involved that's living inside a
woman so that's why he he that that's
why that's not an individual decision
between a woman and her doctor in my
view that's that's a decision between a
woman her doctor and there's a person
can i just ask both of you guys a
question because what i get tired of
is
whether you're on the the left and
you're calling a desantis or a trump an
authoritarian dictator or whether you're
on the right you do the same thing for
obama or de blasio
aren't we being a little hyperbolic when
we're calling anyone in america today
a dictator authoritarian no no not at
all no i mean listen
how many people get compared to freaking
adolf hitler in america there is no
that's different but both sides make
that case and it's it to me it's so
hyper okay first of all you know when
you look at the conversation and i have
studied you know some of these these you
know countries and i have studied the
rise of of the nazis what did they do
they went in and they tried to make it
more difficult for people to vote they
went in and they made it more difficult
for people to protest they then went in
and they segregated parts and blamed
people for for things and then they
started banning
books
this is what is happening in florida we
have a list of where where where he's
banning people from protesting in
florida you're not allowed to protest in
florida did you watch the law that
passed two years ago where he has made
it more difficult for people people
protest in florida peacefully all the
time peacefully yes and and you
shouldn't be protesting violently well
you should never be
violently doing that but what he's done
is said if you are protesting like
somebody who's in a car if there's a
protest you can run through them and if
you happen to if a violence happens or
if something happens and breaks out
instead of these protests somebody
everybody around there can be arrested
what it's doing is deterring people from
showing up and actually protesting i
don't see that at all and i don't if
there's violence i mean you have to shut
down the protesters
if i showed up at a peaceful protest
and violence turned it turned violent in
some capacity everybody there gets do
you think ron desantis has on his agenda
right now to stop to try to inhibit
people from peaceful approach i mean
really can you say that i do
with with it clear because because look
at what he's also done he has not said a
single word about january 6th he has not
said a single word about any of the
nazis that have been coming and
protesting on our streets that in
orlando on three separate occasions he
said nothing about the fact that there
is anti-semitism
flyers that are being passed out in
miami he said nothing about any of these
but yet when black lives matter was out
in the streets that's when those pieces
of legislation came through were they
destroying property no they were not
they were very peaceful protests here in
the state of florida and the fact of the
matter is that is not when the piece of
legislation was filed after january 6 it
was done prior to it and it is deemed
unconstitutional and it is going to get
to the supreme court i'm going to be
honest with you when people look at
issues i mean i understand what you're
saying i hear your perspective i
appreciate your perspective on where
you're coming from but when people look
at issues right now we're in a time
where
people can't get baby formula on the
shelves people can't fill up their car
tanks with gas people can't you know
people can't make a decision in some
places you know what went on in new york
city now the mandates have been lifted
but people were worried about being able
to make a health decision for themselves
and their families without government or
big corporate hands strangling them
every every couple of seconds or forcing
them out of their jobs people are
worried about crime i mean new york city
is destroyed los angeles is destroyed
right now
these that's where the focus is that's
where these dinner table conversations
with if you want to beat someone like
desantis and i assume you do you're
going to have to come in and say these
are the issues where i'm going to do
better than you and that's going to be
really hard because on those issues
florida is rising above all of these
liberal-led states all of them and
people are flooding here for it and for
their businesses for their families for
the safety all of those bullet points
florida check check check that's hard
that's a hard job and i want to know
like how are you going to do that how
are you going to say all these things
going well i'm going to do it better and
here's why well first of all the people
of our state that are living here the
people that are actually every single
day living and working here
when i'm on the campaign trail i don't
talk about these culture issues because
at the end of the day that is not what
people are talking about people are
talking about the fact that they can't
afford food and they can't afford gas
and they can't afford their rent and
they can't afford even to pay property
insurance and their taxes and so the
republicans of today are not talking
about any of those things they're doing
none of it ron desantis put into place a
tax holiday for gas in october october
the month before elections not today not
yesterday not next month whereas every
other state republican states including
virginia has a three months waiver on
taxes i asked for a state of emergency
for for tap for for gas that would have
given me the flexibility because i
oversee some portions of this to waive
some of the parameters when it comes to
fuels that would have allowed some of
our bigger guys to go below cost of
selling of gas because they don't make
their money in the gas stations they
make their money in the convenience
stores or if it's a walmart inside the
actual stores
and and that is something that could
have been productive that could have
actually helped people instead he says
no he says no for whatever reason wants
to blame president biden instead of
realizing that we have solutions here in
the state of florida that can be done
we've got rent increasing all across the
state why though because people want to
be here and people are hiking up the
reds because it's supply basic supply
and demand and you know why we have a
supply problem because republicans for
four four republicans in a row have
gutted the sadowski fund which is the
affordable trust fund which would have
put 2.3 billion dollars
back into the state to build more homes
and so what's happened is that now we
have a supply problem and what's also
happened is that people from these other
states are coming in with high with cash
values and let's also get really real
about why we're also in this situation
donald trump printed six trillion
dollars that they gave out during 2020
and that and they gave the money to a
lot of top one percenters the
corporations who then did their own um
rebates and and cash buybacks to some of
their stockholders and to their vice
presidents and so all this money is into
the ethos which is what has contributed
if not caused the inflation are you
talking about the tax cuts of 2018 or
during 20 during during kovid during
kovid during the trump administration
they gave out six trillion dollars oh
some of that was biden though no no no
this is just the six trillion dollars
that was done during the the during
trump i'm not talking about the
infrastructure right six trillion
dollars was printed and given out during
2020.
it was just the cares act it was 2.1
trillion were you getting six though
because biden came in and he started
printing money though i remember trump
did 2.1 trillion so trump gave out 6
trillion
3 trillion
went to which most people are not
watching this three trillion dollars of
that went to all of the programs that we
all know about the the people correct
all those another three trillion went to
our top corporations that no one paid
attention to no one saw that our
treasury secretary literally had blank
checks that he was giving out to these
maneuvers at the time correct and he
gave out three trillion dollars to these
corporations who were supposed to keep
people on their books keep their
employees employed instead they were
then doing um stock buybacks for their
shareholders were giving salary
increases to themselves and to their
vice presidents so you want to know so
all these people had extra cash and they
came down to florida for all these
reasons for that we've been discussing
and so that bought at the high end of
the market that's why they came down no
no oh my god i said that's why you're
thinking they're coming down here
because of that okay no no no but they
came down and they have all this cash
yeah and now they're buying at the top
of the market and that's done is squeeze
the rest of the market and no one's
talking about that no one's talking
about the fact that we should have been
putting more money into affordable homes
building more homes and instead
so but but the question goes back to so
okay so maybe let me ask a different i
got two questions for you one do you
have any kids i do not okay so two uh
how do you think new york
illinois
and california's policies did during
covet how do you think they did i'm
actually really curious what you're
going to say here
which which states go one atom just to
new york and california how do you think
they how do you think their leaders
handle code listen i don't agree with
how they handled it either tell me what
you don't agree with what what i what
would you do i'm actually really curious
what do you think they didn't do right
so here's what i would have done okay
okay because i can't i don't like i
can't tell you every single decision
that any of the other states i was
solely focused on but you have to
realize if you're gonna sit down and get
the votes of people here who moved from
another state and you can't explain why
they left and you don't know their
pressure points you're gonna have a hard
time getting them to listen to you so
here here's my here's mine sure okay so
first and foremost i did ask for him to
close down because we could have saved
lives and you may not disagree but i'm
telling you signs to be there there is
lots of science like that i i and you
and i a lot of things didn't work the
mask mandates didn't work and the vax
vaxmandics didn't work that we have
plenty of signs to back that up and i i
completely disagree that if we had shut
down or if that were true though nikki
new york wouldn't have had the surges
that it did in california wouldn't have
had the surges that it did despite those
policies in fact new york and california
often times looked a lot worse than
florida well not for very long but that
probably true the point was to have
closed down earlier because if we had
closed down earlier we would have
stopped the spread earlier not people
are getting covered like crazy even now
this isn't different is this totally
different strain they're every there's
70 percent works though you know that i
mean everybody got covet people who were
vacs people who were unvaccinated
different streams waves some of it was
seasonal we know that now we know come
on you know we also all know that people
get vaccinated they're not going to get
into the hospital that's not true either
i know plenty of people who got
vaccinated who landed in the hospital
that's not true yes and some parents
died
that is not true though that's not
that's not to say that people shouldn't
get the vaccine if they want to get the
vaccine or people should have access to
do whatever they want to do for their
health but to argue that shutting down
florida would have prevented the spread
of covenants
let's also realize this desantis did
shut down the state the state was shut
down let's not forget that he did shut
down the state okay he also when i said
it closed it down earlier so we could
open it back earlier that has always
been my position so so every time that
ron wants to say you know the liberals
would shot down the same we'd still be
shut down it's absolutely flat out so
you would have shut it down earlier but
open that it and then did you support
the mandates of the vaccine mandate no
no you didn't i did not i came out and
said personal choice
everybody has to make the decisions i
went against the white house and said
look you know at this point you know
what you need to do to protect yourself
you know what you need to be doing in
order to get your family safe um i did
go on to every single day and ask people
to get the vaccine but certainly i did
not ever agree with with uh with
mandates and the same thing with masks i
clearly said every community needs to
make the decisions of what is best for
them nikki
wait a minute my question's not answered
i'm sorry i'm asking the question if
you're california new york the way that
if you're saying he did such a shitty
job
then you're saying others did a good job
so i'm asking you california and new
york what do you think they did right
that worked so effectively and what do
you think they did wrong that didn't
work so effectively i have never done an
analysis of what new york and california
did i was solely focused i think you
need to because people from those states
are moving to you and you want to be the
governor of this state like if you want
to be the governor of the state i'm a
guy that lived in texas and california i
need you to know why i left california
but i'm telling you what i would have
done at novart okay i came out every
single day when when ron was not giving
information and that has been
his decisions aren't always necessarily
what my point of issue is my point of
issue is the fact that he
made sure that his opinion was the only
opinion he wasn't listening to any other
advice he wasn't listening to any other
experts besides the ones that he brought
to the table and you still you have a
purple state he won by 33 000 you had
half of the state that was scared you
had half the state that saw people that
are dying in hospitals that didn't know
what information to be given and then
you have somebody who comes on and yells
at anybody who doesn't agree with him he
didn't create a calmness he created
chaos he didn't bring people to the
table that may have different opinions
and talk through it it was his way or
the highway he changed the way that that
we were looking at data he brought down
the the um the dashboard with all this
information people were going through
this blind without information so so do
you think all these people who are
educated people
who have families kids from new york
california dc east coast who move to
florida are not paying attention to
these numbers like do you think they
came down here because they're oblivious
why do you think these families move
down here look i don't know why are they
the oblivious crowd that moved to
florida like listen he saw he sold this
this picture of what was happening in
the state of florida that we are the
free state of florida that we are open
but then if you go down to the policies
he was picking and choosing winners and
losers he was saying okay wwe and
jacksonville you can open up but the
rest of the state you can't
and then he was choosing which types of
different types of businesses were able
to have a seat at the table and even
with the vaccines look at how he
distributed the vaccines he first had
pop-up locations that were in affluent
communities he then put the vaccines
into publixes and as commissioner of
agriculture i know how many food deserts
are across the state of florida and
minority communities could not get
access to these vaccines
those were the issues that i had a
problem with you know whether or not to
have closed down when he did i asked to
be on the reopening task force that
because at this point he again not
bringing people to the table kept me off
of the reopening task force i enforced
when he came out with the reopening uh
task force and the recommendations i
actually supported them
i said these are these are methodical
these are well thought out and then he
completely scrapped it and just reopened
but i think we got to get back to this
issue
regardless of what happened with the
pandemic
we got to go and move past it you know
we know i don't think we can though
when it comes down to if you're if
you're talking about specific to this
topic i know what you're doing but i'm
talking in this stuff we're not past
this topic yet
why did so many educated people who care
about their kids and their wives and
their families and their husbands why
did they move to florida
should they all leave now no should they
go back to california texas should they
go back to new york they should go back
right if you're saying they made a
mistake coming down here because the
santas did such a terrible job i got
three people here that did a super chat
i just want to read it real quick
because one of them said
uh uh in regards to why he didn't let
you guys make the decisions for yourself
i don't know this one's super chat said
desantis stripped the power
because you all failed this is not
rocket science this is what one you'll
respond to him them
daniel rivera said the democrats banned
dr seuss books the democrats silenced
the conservatives over the 2020 election
disney fired gina carano and canceled
the woman there are people locked up
over peaceful protests on january 6.
democrats don't care about america now
this is that this is the comments and
then this other guy very peaceful cove
12x said any new yorker the dinner table
conversation is when we are moving to
florida
because of desantis we never consider
florida move that's your context so
that's what they're saying but going
back to it all these people that moved
to florida they're very happy i'd love
to see a few interviews about people
that moved to florida that are miserable
today i do i speak to people all the
time and they say they made a mistake
moving here i'd love to see that
there's a lot of people in florida who
are pissed off no their rents have
skyrocketed 30 something
that's a dead that's a real thing but
that's that's called supply and demand
you're in business you should know that
that's called capitalism that's supply
and demand but if you're one of them
on the msnbc hit show that they did on
desantis which nikki was on they
interviewed a guy husband and wife they
said we came and we're paying thousand
dollars rent for a year and a half ago
you remember this and he said and they
increased my rent by 30 percent and it
says so how did you handle that he says
well the the landlord told me you can go
elsewhere but that's the market right
and he's like i went everywhere else it
was more than 30 so i had to pay the
1300 bucks that's called
capitalism but you called it a rate but
but you call the dress let me finish
this then you can push back i mean let's
uh change the topics to people that live
here you have a point we'll get to that
here in a minute all i'm asking for is
the people that moved here i don't know
anybody who's unhappy to move here which
means just like a lot of immigrants who
come to america who love america and
americans [ __ ] about america they don't
know what it is to live in a different
place so you lived in texas and you
lived here you've not lived in
california you've not lived in new york
and she's not lived in new york and
california you guys don't know what it
was to live at these places that's why
people are leaving so as much as we want
to say wow this well this well that
totally get it we're coming to you
because all your stuff you're bitching
about we are very happy about we are
very happy about the stuff that this guy
has done so that's all i'm saying with
the argument so if people you're meeting
who have moved you who are not happy
tell me why they say they're not happy
you know they're coming down here and
people have come here and i and i speak
to people okay all day long all walks of
life and when i hear they say they come
down here they've moved down here and
they didn't realize how bad the culture
wars were that they have a kid who
potentially is a member of the lgbtq no
one's saying that i haven't heard that
no one's saying that well i don't know
who you all are talking to we have kids
we have kids i i get it we are around
people with kids and i and i'm around
people with kids all day long and we
have like i have four kids like i know
what happens in schools i'm i'm the guy
that's talking to these people with
other parents i haven't heard anybody
saying oh they're not letting my kid
choose what they want to be i'm saying
that that that they because of some of
these policies which ones which policies
the one with lgbt which is disney go
ahead please continue that's kind of
where you're going with so and that was
just one example yeah but what i'm
hearing across the board is we didn't
realize how contentious this was and how
much tension there is on the ground you
can't talk to your neighbors that now
we're dealing with things that are
inside the education can you please
interview these guys and put a video out
absolutely can you please interview
these guys and and allow us as well to
speak to them i i'll be happy i'm
telling you i talk to people all the
time that have moved we do too though
but we do as well okay but but here's
but here's what i'm gonna push back on
please do so okay you're you're
attacking me on i'm not attacking you
what i'm saying is what i'm saying is
i'm saying your governor's done a good
job on why so many are moving
you can go to the areas that have he's
not done a good job fine you can bring
those up but in this area when it comes
down to stuff that she talked about and
she made a very good point when it comes
on to families with kids no taxes
leaving me be who i am let me be free
the things that matter to us that has to
do with fundamentals that america offers
this has been the best state the last
two years there's not been a better
state than this state the last two years
and obviously i disagree and that's and
that's that's fine that's why you're
here to push a push you have to say
what's a better state than florida these
days because let me just weigh in i ask
i have tons of friends that have moved
here from new york specifically
the i i want them to leave they're my
friends i'm like please guys go back to
new york they're like we're not we're
not leaving
like almost like jordan bell for like
we're not leaving
all of them nikki i want them to leave i
i was paying rent this much it
skyrocketed that's i'll be okay i've got
some money in the bank but there's a lot
of friends out there that do not and as
much as you're saying no there's a lot
of people unhappy i talk to these people
my job is to talk to people for a living
they're all staying and i want them to
leave and they're my friends so you
can't say that you're running into a lot
of people who are unhappy moving here
they wouldn't move here if they were
unhappy here well a lot of them don't
understand what some of the culture
issues when they get to the ground and
especially if they're a minority
community a lot more culture issues in
la or new york
florida's been purple forever i don't
fight with anybody if i go to california
i'm fighting with the republican i'm
even fighting with democrats same thing
in brooklyn new york there's not that
much fighting here in florida and that's
why i love florida i i haven't debated
this much people since i've been around
more people from la and new york florida
i got cuban friends haitian friends this
person that person jewish friends it's
more of a melting pot than all these
other states you know i'm wondering if
the issue is like anywhere you move is
not going to be perfect for you there's
going to be something about it the
energy the vibe you're talking about
cultural issues you're going to find
something that doesn't work for you but
the challenge is is that if you compare
like a new york to a florida or a
lawsuit i mean there are places these
cities are sinking around the country
many of them are sinking what people are
saying to themselves is
maybe florida's not perfect but on these
issues that really matter like you're
not talking about anything if you can't
feed your family
that comes number one there are priority
issues for people if you can't put gas
in your tank it doesn't matter you can't
get where you need to go you can't worry
about all of this other stuff that's
secondary so on those priority issues
people by and large and i say this as
somebody who wasn't like i don't love
the climate in florida that would not
have been my first choice i would have
been waiting there all right
this would not have been my first choice
i i always wanted to move to los angeles
and i'm deeply heartbroken that i can't
move there because it's being buried
right now and i don't feel safe raising
my two-year-old there but i think the
issue is like there are core issues that
people feel florida's doing those right
and and and if they and if florida
wasn't doing those right you would see a
mass exodus of people from florida to
new york city to los angeles you know if
if the cultural issues on the ground in
florida were so horrible and people who
had you know if lgbtq whatever it is
whatever your issue is if that was the
priority issue you would see those
numbers moving the other way they're not
well
but
you know because at the end of the day
and which is why i don't talk about
culture wars on a normal basis i talk
about economics economics 101 that
that's why people vote but the people
that are suffering here in our state and
i'm glad that you can afford 30 percent
of 40 or 60 increase in your rent but
the people that i talk to every day
i had a call yesterday with somebody
going i'm getting evicted i can't afford
an extra seven that's what i'm saying is
the majority of my friends are
struggling like that i'm not i'm not
disagreeing they're struggling and
there's been no conversations about how
to fix it and so people are sitting here
and i am talking to people saying i'm
going to have no choice but to leave
this day because i can't afford to live
here anymore but in miami the number one
city in the state that's not on desantis
isn't that on mayor suarez i mean what
do you have to say about what he's done
whole other thing
i i think it goes back to the same
fundamental issue okay look and this is
why i'm running for governor
is is to make sure that there are
differences of opinions obviously you
hear that in this room it's great that's
fantastic but what has happened in our
state is that those differences of
opinions and those different
conversations don't see the light of day
because they're shut down
desantis does not he how many cabinet
meetings has he canceled on me because
he refuses to listen to what i have to
say how many times has he not listened
to the people in the room that he's
yelled at at reporting other states
other states like like this doesn't
happen in other states i'm just i i am
talking about florida okay my my my
friends so listen i think you guys you
gotta you something happened between the
two of you guys that you guys got you
know that's that's you guys gotta have
some lunch one day but but but by the
way by the way let's talk about rent
because that is an issue that comes up i
just had a meeting with hr this week
having to do with rent and that is
happening but i have offices and 49 i
have 150 offices my insurance company
all across the country and we have these
conversations about rent and i got to
tell you
rent is increasing in the markets that
attracted the most people that moved
there for example when i first moved to
plano texas
uh
you know everybody would say wow let me
tell you if you knew plano 15 years ago
this place was a desert right i'm like
okay then they would show me pictures
right
well i bet when plano was a desert rent
was probably 20 bucks a month
and now rent in plano's 2 grand a month
is that a mistake does that mean people
are moving there that's a good sign that
means economy is going there but the
problem shows up afterwards right then
you have to come up with policies that
you got to address and that it's true
that's something you have to do so we're
going to see how that's going to be
handled now amongst the company or
amongst the state or amongst the
capitalists the job creators and some
people may not be able to afford it some
people may say i just can't afford to
live here and like in l.a give you an
idea in l.a there's a city called
palmdale lancaster palmdale is an an
hour away from la okay when rent in l.a
is going to three four thousand dollars
tens of thousands of families move to
palmdale and lancaster same thing's
gonna happen here as well some people
that can't live in a market they're
right now they're probably going to be
moving that's very normal across the
board every day that's not a florida
issue that's an every state issue that's
growing but but here's the problem okay
this is the fundamental problem there's
twofold one is
because we have been gutting our
affordable trust fund 2.3 billion
dollars over the last 25 years
jeb did it
charlie did it rick did it and ron's
done it so you now have less homes that
have been built for the lower level what
i was just saying beforehand all these
people have come to the state that have
bought the top of the market and have
crushed the bottom of the market the
people that are hurting are the bottom
of the market and they don't have
anywhere else to go and these are the
people that are literally the number one
economic driver for our state is tourism
number two is is agriculture both of
those industries are the lowest paying
in the in industries in in the country
and so when you have individuals that
are literally making up our economy the
tourist industry and agriculture
industry what happens when everybody in
the tourist industry can't afford to
live here who's making our baristas
who's making who's going to be picking
our our
fruits and vegetables who's going out to
the movie theaters and working the movie
stands where is our teachers living they
can't afford to live here we are funding
education 49th in the nation you will
talk about new york and california and
other states that have we're the third
largest gdp in the nation third after
those two states but yet we're funding
education 49th in the nation that tells
you that our priorities are backwards
and our education system is falling
apart
healthcare we're funding healthcare 50th
in the nation we haven't expanded
medicaid so well i'm curious though
because you mentioned education that's
that's a topic near and dear to me i was
a teacher for many years um so what is
your what is your fix to that because i
know that desantis has been out there
talking about school choice and that's a
topic many parents are passionate about
because they're concerned about their
ability whether they have money or not
some don't have money but they want to
be able to send their kids to the
schools that they want to send them to
what is your fix to an educational
system that's broken in florida well
first of all we as floridians voted for
the lottery to make sure that lottery
money was to go towards education
and that was supposed to be in addition
to
so back in 2006 we had per pupil funding
at around 6 400. we're at 6 900 today
between 2006 and 2022 if you look at
inflation it should be over ten thousand
dollars just to keep up with inflation
so what we have done is we have gutted
our traditional public schools and i'm a
proud proud product of our public
education system in miami-dade county as
was my parents they all were also from
the miami dade and what we've done is we
have gutted our traditional public
schools and so we've taken money out of
our our traditional public schools and
we have allocated into
any other place not even not even just
general other education we've gutted it
and so what we have to be doing is
putting more money back into our
education system okay so i'm going to
tell you though money's not going to fix
the educational system because new york
places like that have been funneling
money into education for decades and
decades it doesn't work the way that you
fix an educational system is the way
that you fix every system as you put
competition into that system and you
force you force those schools to fire
bad teachers to pay good teachers higher
you you force those parents to have the
option to choose where they send their
kids to school every single district you
look at everywhere in the country that
allows for school choice sees a rise in
educational opportunities for families
and a rise in standard of education for
kids so if you want to fix the
educational system truly and i believe
that you do based on what you're saying
that's how you fix it well and i don't
disagree with all of that you know but
she makes a good point though and i
don't have kids just like you i don't i
mean but school choice seems like
capitalism at its finest what's wrong
with that
because everybody is entitled to a
quality education system and when you
take money out of our traditional public
schools which are still the bedrock most
if you talk about people want to go into
choice if you look at the statistics
still 75 plus percent of our parents are
still making the choice to put their
kids into public traditional public
schools and they're failing them those
schools are failing them but that's also
because the fact is that if you are
talking about our private schools or
charter schools that are paying more
money for their teachers that we're
losing to we have 6 500 shortage of
teachers that we are asking parents to
come in as substitute teachers
they're making nothing they're making
nothing in december i was on those
salaries i know what they look like and
so was my mom you know she taught for 25
years i heard those stories heard the
stories of our teachers buying school
supplies for their kids because there's
not enough school supplies in the
classrooms
and and what we have done is is money
enough no absolutely but that has to
start somewhere that we have schools and
we want to look at something interesting
that at a third grade reading
that 90 percent of our black kids at
third grade reading are reading below
poverty line and we are we base where
how many jails and prisons we build
based on that third greed third grade
reading but you can't blame first of all
you're gonna have to look at family
structures for that you're gonna have to
go back to the dinner table you're gonna
have to look at is that does that child
have the support of well we can't we can
go into that hope you have to talk about
community you have to talk about church
i mean there's there are layers deep of
this but you're not going to throw money
at that at that school and fix that kid
you're going to the way that you're
going to give that kid an opportunity
let that parent or that guardian pick
where that kid goes to school and if
that school is failing that kid
shut her down shut her down why would
money help though if like if you're
saying teacher's going to come out of
pocket to buy because you know why they
waste a ton of money like every other
government institution they waste a ton
of money you don't see it and then you
have teachers unions you don't agree
with that nikki you don't think
government
oh government that wastes lots of money
the governor just did 109 billion budget
i can find a whole lot more he'd only be
to a 3.1 billion i could have vetoed a
whole heck of a lot more in there there
you go so an education no no military i
don't care what department you're
talking about every single institution
of government there is waste there's
fraud there's abuse education is part of
that of course and look i have put forth
my i oversee a 1.3 billion budget inside
the department of agriculture every
single every single session i've put
forth a more conservative budget than my
republican predecessors did because i
didn't want to waste money i made sure
that we had the exact money that we
needed to run the department and the
programs that we needed to do to whether
it's increasing um our the amount of
money that's coming in for agriculture
to making sure our water quality is in
there i asked for 83 new positions for
concealed weapons programming because
again we have the largest concealed
weapons program in the entire country
here in the state of florida that i
regulate i ask for 83 more positions
because we are overwhelmed and the
governor vetoed those 83 positions
because he has his own agenda of what he
wants to do with guns i guess what what
my struggle is is you're running in
florida and
what
i guess what what i you know what i'm
trying to speak to you is people people
who who came here
came here because they care about
freedom when someone like desantis said
i don't i don't i don't know desantis i
don't have any personal like he i don't
know him he's a stranger to me but when
he speaks words like school choice when
he speaks words like you know freedom
and autonomy over your own health and
healthcare decisions when he his house
without abortion abortion is a very
complex topic we could have a whole hour
on that which we don't have right now
but when he talks about schools and
parental rights in schools everybody
talked about don't say gay bill don't
say gay wasn't in the bill and it wasn't
about that it was about parental rights
those are issues that for me i'm a mom
you know i'm somebody who did not grow
up with money i'm somebody who believes
in opportunity i'm somebody who wants to
keep more of my heart earned cash
because that's that's going to be my
kids money one day these are things that
speak to me freedom opportunity choice
you spoke about opportunity in the
beginning and i guess what i want you to
sort of walk away from this is just
understanding i don't care liberal
democrat republican these labels mean
nothing to me what i want is somebody
who's going to fight for individuals and
who's going to fight for real
opportunity and that looks like low
taxes that looks like schools to teach
reading writing and math and not you
know trying to persuade you to feel this
way or that way that's not what school's
supposed to be and that's not what
they're doing either like well it is
happening across the country and it
happened in schools i taught in in new
york city and it does happen there's a
lot of misinformation about all of this
and it's gotten so out of control and
and the fact but do you do you want what
that message that do you believe that
someone like you could speak to somebody
like me and get me to vote for you of
course so then right now can you can you
tell me why i should vote for you
absolutely because the end of the day i
want to make sure that you've got a
florida that is safe for your children
in school you've got a two-year-old she
a girl a boy that's a boy hartley
want to make sure that they're safe in
school that they've got a good
educational environment that you have an
opportunity to succeed in the state of
florida that makes also that you have
affordability on housing
and there are things that haven't come
into place i asked also for that tax for
the um for the gas um emergency because
the fact not only was it going to help
people at the gas pump do you support uh
energy independence for the country do
you support worse okay we've got to get
there i mean look what's happened i mean
we i mean look what's happening so you
support drilling you support whatever
needs to happen in order to make that
happen i support us look there's this is
why i legalized hemp in the state of
florida because hemp is going to be an
alternative to biofuel it's going to be
a biofuel it is all biodegradable
products that can be made with instead
of these little
i love that listen i love hemp we can
agree on that and we can also agree on
marijuana legalization i know you feel
that way
which is interesting i've never smoked
weed in my life i can't stand the smell
of it but i'm such a freedom fighter i'm
like legalizing it look at youtube
finding common ground on marijuana there
was no but i'm saying but like on that
that's a libertarian approach right you
know and i'm and that's where and the
truth of the matter is this
all the things you're talking about
freedom that is a one-sided freedom
decision conversation because let me
tell you the conversations that i have
are i feel like my freedom is being
taken away every single day i'm hearing
that that's how i felt in new york
that's why i'm here but then that's fine
but the fact of the matter is like let's
just talk about yesterday okay yesterday
the governor
threatened to hold back 27 million
dollars from the special olympics yeah
we actually have that article i don't
know that was a real thing it was a real
thing i supported that
but you supported
taking money away from the special
olympics well he he about the mandate
the vaccine
olympics the mandate and what happened i
don't know
i want to see what this article is
they backed down because they needed the
money but the fact that because he's
fighting for people's individual
freedoms we're talking about the special
olympics a mandate to get a vaccine this
should be the decision of
that organization no and i'll i'll tell
you why because that's a great point you
bring up people say to me all the time
oh but that's private business that's
the free market you have to let private
that's not what's happening here in the
country you're having big corporations
hold hands with big government exchange
favors
get this get that you have big pharma
funds a ton of these people
and you have somebody like ron desantis
coming in and saying oh no hold on a
second i want to enable individuals in
my state to make these decisions for
themselves and i'm not going to let big
corporations holding hands with big
government holding hands with big pharma
take that rights away from myself
because i'm telling you it will be a
losing argument to go against desantis
on mandates the whole country flocked
here to back him on that but i disagree
because he guess you talk about
republicans must be about free market
and it's supposed to be about businesses
doing their own thing
if the special olympics it is a pri an
organization that decided that it was
trying to protect the people that are
participating
how does it protect them you you can get
and pass the virus if you're vaccinated
this is this is this is politics it says
in science the politics is that he did
that instead of allowed it okay they
want to talk about something else the
facts matters look at what he did in key
west you want to talk about something in
key west the key west people the people
of key west who had done a a market
study who went out and saw campaigns
decided the people of key west decided
that they did not want the big cruise
ships coming into the port because they
felt that it was only a five dollars and
34 cents of the average person spends
when they're coming into the key west
and the amount of money that is spent on
cleaning on policing and the fact that
it was also hurting the coral reefs the
people of key west said no
governor got a one million dollar
campaign contribution
and forced a reversal i don't know
anything i can't comment on that because
i don't think this is the thing that i
see this is the thing that i see every
single day it seems to me like you have
a problem you you feel like
i don't mean to put words in your mouth
but it seems to me that your main issue
with desantis is that you feel that
people with dissenting views don't have
a seat at the table that is 100 correct
okay that's what i'm so and that's
something that
you know i mean listen we're all sitting
here right now and we're all talking
this out and we all disagree but i will
say this when somebody wins an election
he sees the world and the country and
the state and very differently from you
you you would handle things very
differently somebody does win and like i
always say elections have consequences
joe biden is president and i don't agree
with most of what he does but he won he
won that election i hope he doesn't win
again but regardless somebody does
you hope he doesn't win again
of course desantis uh joe biden oh
yeah
i mean listen
but
but but but here's the thing he won by
33 000 i'm just going to say that can i
can i just give you like a little layup
here but
nikki at one point said this is a purple
state that there's half the state it
agrees with him no purpose it's still
perfect 100 by the way 100 okay we'll
see and by the way the i4 corridor is
basically what splits the state yes or
no yes okay you've got a lot of red in
this state right now yeah that's the i-4
corridor i mean i think you have letting
you know it's a purple state do your
research got you
however
that flip though you guys got two more
on the republican side
it's trending the different way no no no
it's historic say it correctly though
because that's what happened based on
data
republicans picked up two more so it
flipped that's what happened to florida
but continually and we could go into
holding that happening
that's just no no no no no no no no no
no no no
that's what's what's happened yeah with
the right trending you may not like it
but that's what's happening
because of desantis continue but
she does have a point that half the
state thought certain way half the state
now if you want to say no it's 55 45
cool whatever but
they're even 60 40. cool whatever
but my question to you is though
the race that desantis won in 2018 i
believe very close neck and neck with
andrew gillum yep so my question to you
is all right desantis won clearly
there's some advocacy for him
what would be different if andrew gillum
won like desantis came in people are
flocking could a case be made that that
wouldn't have been the case with gillum
like
give desantis maybe a little bit of
credit here like what would be different
if gillum was the governor versus
desantis yeah i i i think that what
would have happened differently is that
you would not have had this cultural
division that you wouldn't have had a
governor who only thought that he was
only right and did not listen to other
viewpoints and that is what democracy is
supposed to be about that you're
supposed to have people on both sides of
the aisle that are supposed to come
together and make decisions that are for
the best interests of our state what it
doesn't happen in any state i'm going to
be honest with you but that never
happened in new york i mean i got a vote
in new york
that's how you just got here this is how
florida used to be
this florida used to be that way i used
to be able to charlie crist
i mean i talked to bob graham all the
time she does have a point here we all
used to i talked to jeb all the time i
was student body president during time
of jebs and i talk to jeb all the time i
still talk to rick scott all the time
during some of this pandemic stuff rick
was calling me and i was calling him
that's what it's supposed to be about in
fact i was in washington dc last week
and i was talking to my federal affairs
director and marco calls our office to
work with us all the time rubio yeah
that that is what it's supposed to be
about and i was duly elected flipping a
seat by a million votes i hear what
you're saying and there's no there's no
coming together and the recognition you
won by 33 000. there's dif there's how
many total people voted 8.3 million
didn't 8 million people vote free and
you only won by 6 753 votes and that's
why i talked to republicans all day long
yeah but you also barely won that is
correct okay so what's the point the
point is that i flipped a seat by almost
a million votes a democrat hasn't won
commissioner agriculture in over 20
years no female has ever won commission
of agriculture i recognized that i
didn't win by a hundred thousand five
hundred thousand and so you know when i
did my first legislative session all of
my pieces of legislation were sponsored
by republicans
i'm gonna tell you though that and i
hear what you're saying about wanting
people to come together and i i lived in
that head for a very long time and i'll
tell you when it flipped from me
it flipped from me when the mandates
happened and i realized that there were
people on the other side of the aisle
that wanted that would take that would
bury me in five seconds if they had the
chance that is not regardless that is
not what's happening in this moment
because there's a big segment of the
country there's two big segments of the
country on both sides sides of the aisle
who feel very differently i mean you
talk about gun control you can talk
about crime you can talk about the
police you can every issue
it's two different worlds two different
ways of thinking it's going to be very
hard and those people you're talking
about i mean jeb bush he doesn't appeal
to me as a conservative marco rubio
right now doesn't appeal to me a
conservative i'm looking at the rand
pauls of the world i'm looking at the
ron desantis of the world
conservatives people on the right and
people who are center-right are very
drawn to these fighters
people who aren't going to sit down and
say well i'll give a little and you give
a little because that little that they
give away is damaging but that's what
democracy is supposed to
we're not even a democracy truthfully
but
great that sounds great that's that
sounds beautiful on paper but when it
comes down to it people right now are in
a moment where they're like i need to
take care of my family my kids they've
just got that
but that's what you're describing is
what's wrong with america right now okay
that right now because that's not how it
used to be i have a master's in
political campaigning i have a master's
from you know a degree in politics
and every time every time i have been
involved besides when this went south
with desantis i told you that we started
this conversation i walked into a
cabinet that i had been friends with
ashley moody since underground in law
school i've known jimmy patronis since
his time in the legislature i walked in
as the head of the democratic party
saying let's find things that we can
work together on whether it's the
environment whether it's support for the
state of israel whatever it is
that we tried to work on compromise in
the first legislative session all of my
bills were sponsored by republicans
and that they're what kind of
republicans though the mitch mcconnells
of the world that drive me crazy the
people who don't dig in their heels and
fight
this is what i'm saying but if you and i
sat down right now and we say we were
trying to work together on something we
might maybe the medical marijuana or the
marijuana legalization we would be you
guys should probably go smoke a joint
i'm just throwing that out
i've never smoked a joint well it's
starting now we're gonna make some
changes
a pot brownie after the show but no
really i'm sure that issue but we would
have a really hard time because we
wouldn't
yeah trying to go out tonight guys yeah
he's thinking miami it might get close
to 420. that's all he's thinking about
that's a good point
watch us finish it exactly
you know my point is just we would have
a really hard time working together in
the sense of we may like each other we
may get along but i want very different
things for this country and if i were
running my platform would look very
different from yours
sounds like you're making a campaign
for something no but i'm tired of of
politics as usual it seems like
politicians get into a room and they all
shake hands and they come out and it's
like
do any did you any of you fight did you
dig in
policy wise what are you saying that
you're wholeheartedly different from her
saying that i would be fighting for
school choice and i would be rapping
and even patrol i want people to i want
that second amendment upheld and
protected i i want i feel very strongly
about that okay so let's let's talk
about those two issues okay let's talk
about what you just talked about choice
i'm not opposed to choice
not a point it's a choice at all you
know in fact like i said i i've said
this also very publicly i had a learning
disability when i was growing up and
luckily i was in a school that it was
recognized and that i got special
attention to make sure that that
happened right and
so not every child fits into the
traditional school setting that's right
that that is see we're agreeing okay
but but i don't agree with taking money
away from our traditional schools to put
them in choice so you increase the
amount of education and money going in
there and i know there's other i mean we
can talk for other hours about what yeah
and we would and i think that i think
that this presents itself as you know
i hear what you're saying you want
people to come together more you want
you want you want politics to be more
palatable you know in terms of it being
i understand that but that's what you're
that's not the moment we're in i'm going
to be honest with you
which it's just not which is why charlie
crist won't win this election okay
because he's not a fighter well he's you
and i can probably agree on him to be
frank you know but and and so yes and i
am a fighter for what i believe in and
for the things that i have
i want to do
you got one minute i got to get you out
of here no no i'm just i'm responding to
a text i'm getting so give us your final
thoughts here first of all you know
whatever
you can say whether you agreed with or
disagreed with you or disagree with me
or whoever it is
i've said this always i have so much
respect for anybody who's willing to
come and sit here and have this kind of
a conversation you have no idea how much
respect you get from me just to be able
to handle a conversation like this and
take it because we know both sides of
the aisle people only want to go sit
with people that's going to be what
here's the staff hey you know just go
say whatever you want to say and
everyone's going to support you you're
so awesome you're so great why don't you
do this and i think that's a problem i
applaud you for doing that so final
thoughts audience listening to this
uh if you had the final message here to
say why somebody ought to consider
voting for you why would that why would
that be look i'm somebody who wants to
reach across the aisle and to work
together that is what the people of our
state that's why that we got might be
elected and ron desantis in the same
exact election the people of our state
want don't want this divisiveness they
don't want the spewing of hatred and
it's on both sides it's on both sides of
the extremes on both sides of the aisle
i'm not the extreme i am the center of
the road um i'm outside the box i'm not
a traditional democrat i'm somebody
who's going to fight for issues not for
not for a party and i think that at the
end of the day people want somebody
who's going to show up who's going to be
true who's going to be real who's we may
not always agree on things but the fact
of the matter is like you just said that
we're going to have a conversation i
respect that and that's who i am that's
who i have always been nikki can we put
the what's the website what if people
want to follow your website it's
nickifree.com can you put that in the
chat and put in the comment section so
people can find her
uh uh nikki we're going to continue but
they're going to come and open the door
here too
let you make it to your meeting but this
is uh the website and put that below as
well appreciate you so much for coming
out thank you truly thank you so much
this was fantastic what's your what's
your youtube we'll send a link to the
youtube i don't know if you're trying to
increase your youtube
yes and whoever's texting me rob was
that you texting me
somebody take some pvp
eight four is it impossible to shake
hands chris
chris text me or no
okay folks stick around cause i got an
announcement you're coming over here
yeah if you can sit over here nikki that
was great i'll put john uh in touch and
all that truly enjoyed it thank you yeah
thank you yes okay awesome
okay guys uh yeah we typically don't do
a saturday podcast but we had uh nikki
who agreed to do this and
when she said yes i'd i'd love to have a
conversation with her even though
oh are you kidding me understatement how
much fun by the way when you're telling
her to her face how much you respect her
you're not bsing i know how much respect
you have for someone with opposing views
that comes and sit here whether it's
andrew yang or jank weaker whoever you
have a lot of respect for those are my
favorite conversations those are my
favorite conversations but i tell you
but i tell you this folks
if you enjoyed like this entire time i'm
sitting there watching her and i have a
conversation and i'm enjoying that
conversation that was my favorite part
yeah
but by the way you know
poised you know respectful all of that i
mean you know jeddah that has gone
against hillary clinton so when he going
against heavyweights anybody
i was very impressed by her i'm not
saying that we agreed or disagreed on
every but nikki as far as a person and
carrying herself
i think she's pretty i enjoyed the
debate hi caliber this was grandfather
we're going to do many many more of
these so folks stick around but we got
to make announcements yes or no yeah we
got enough i'm gonna let you do it yeah
so let me let me let me tell you what
happened so i think
some of the audience knows some of you
don't know some of you guys that are
members here that are signing up to
become members uh uh uh you know i'm
excited for you because you'll see why
there's going to be other benefits of
being members if you haven't yet may
want to consider being a member so
first time jedidiah was on a podcast how
many months ago was that was that like
six seven months ago about six or six
yeah was it that long no it was not
because it was in this in this
so we sat down we spoke right afterwards
i'm like
man i love this the way she talks i love
the world you know energy did you admit
was it the three of us yes okay would
you admit what you said to me you're
like i gotta go but go recruit her would
you
i was like hey
which is exactly that's exactly what
happened what are you up to after this
100
good to know that we're making things
happen so
yeah that's right so then we have
conversations and one thing led to
another and then a multiple conversation
with jeremy and then i said what would
this look like and then you were kind of
sharing this and anyways we're here to
announce to everybody that's watching
this that jedediah has officially joined
the valuetainment team and i got to tell
you we're ecstatic that's an
understatement to see how ecstatic we
are to have yourself jeremy hartley now
being down here in florida and getting
more of you and valuetainment the
audience who loved you when he had john
so matter of fact are you okay if we
show the video let's show the pro movies
do it let's go okay go ahead play the
promo video
[Music]
i'm jetta diabeela
i've hosted and co-hosted cable news
shows network tv shows all of it
i hated the filters and there were many
i struggled with the time constraints
that stifled conversation i sometimes
felt like i was drowning in producer
direction
what i wanted was to get to the heart of
big issues to be real and to have an
honest conversation with people who
agreed with me and disagreed with me
people who would make us think and help
fix what's broken
i couldn't do what i wanted to do what i
needed to do in the spaces i was in
so i was ready to find a new space
i believe so strongly in individual
freedom i love this country but it's a
mess right now and i'm not going to
sugarcoat that with fake giggles and
rainbows i want to talk about why things
are so [ __ ] up not just in politics
but everywhere health fitness dating
culture it all needs a good hard look
welcome to my new zone this is jetta
diabilo live on valuetainment
i'm excited about that jennifer i know
i'm so excited when you watch that promo
video you're just like you kind of like
want to work out you want to do
something i gotta give a shout out to
the editing team that yeah the
production team they're amazing and let
me tell you we had such a fun day
shooting that it was amazing um it's
it's a great team here all around um and
was that a real workout you were doing
on the view so yeah
i work out like crazy um and we're gonna
do some fun stuff on the show related to
that we're gonna we're gonna have some
amazing guests um it's gonna be a lot of
me ranting it's gonna be everything's on
the table so it's not just politics
people know me from politics i'm big
into health and wellness fitness
pop culture dating we're going to cover
it all we're going to be real and we're
going to dig you know i really want to
like do some deep dives i want to have a
real conversation
and if we have a guest it's going to be
someone that i really want to talk to my
goal here is to make people feel
powerful over their own lives again i
feel like there's a lot of sentiments
out there of negativity people feel
powerless they feel like they're kind of
like shrinking in their seats it's been
a tough two years i want to remind
people that a lot is possible and it's
right within their reach so it's going
to be it's going to be fun and it's
going to be crazy
we saw the amazing promo again shout out
to the to the production team yeah you
were on uh fox you were on the view
you've been around but yeah and even
when you were independent you were
talking to other networks and other
outlets
eventually were very grateful that you
chose and
came to valuetainment what was the the
biggest piece of the puzzle you said all
right pat
let's do this why valuetainment you know
i had a few conversations with pat and i
just really felt like and i was talking
to people who you know are super
respected in the industry all great
people amazing i feel incredibly lucky
that you know any any of you guys you
know were excited to work with me um but
pat just had something really
interesting i felt like there was a real
commitment to a free speech zone i felt
like he wanted to really talk to people
who he agreed with and disagreed with it
didn't feel like it was ideologically
just one way i felt like i could really
go into my own space and be myself dress
like i wanted to dress talk the way i
wanted to talk
feel very unfiltered in that space and
honestly i have a lot of respect for you
and your i'm not good with money and
you're amazing with money and you're an
entrepreneur and i have so many ideas of
things i want to do but
i could use like someone in
in my life in a business sense that
could i could shoot ideas off of that i
have that kind of respect for and i just
i have a lot of respect for people who
you know come from very little and
financially and work their way up and
build something um and it was just a
vibe too i was here with you guys i just
felt like we kind of all meshed together
well um it was a lot of just gut feeling
you know like i think
i think desantis being in florida kind
of was was a push for me as well um
and it just felt right you know i know
people say that and it's cheesy but it
just felt like the right move and pat i
know you've been talking to other people
what was it about jedediah that you were
like all right cool
let's let's try to get her are you
kidding me today was the best commercial
i i could have listened to them for four
hours i'm not even kidding with you i
could listen two or four hours and the
stuff that was coming back where it's
like yeah but you got to say this and it
wasn't disrespectful it was proper it
was pushed back i mean uh uh yeah look
i'm a big believer when i see talent
then i say i tell i told you 10 years
ago nice i'm like this guy's got
something i said you got it right
thank you but when i saw jedediah and
i'm like researching all the other stuff
she did i'm like
she's got something she's got a message
the world's got to hear it i think
there's so many other men and women who
want to hear from a alpha female so this
is a woman who's a mother married
husband who's a stud you know he's a
winner but at the same time she's got a
message that other women are sitting
there saying i relate to you i'm
somebody that's going through this i
have these concerns i have these fears i
want to hear that i think millions are
going to flock to listen to her message
and i think she's going to make a major
impact in a lot of people's lives and
that's that's what i'm most excited
about which is so exciting times and
futures
so tell us how many times a week can
people find you you're going to be able
to so we're going to start next
wednesday is the first show at 1 00 p.m
i'm super excited jenna diablo live and
then we're going to be three times a
week after that so you're going to get
to hear from me uh monday to wednesday
kai who's in the room right now with us
is going to be with me on wednesday that
was the biggest mistake we made
in advance i want to apologize on behalf
of the team you know but it is what it
is just know he's going to bring a lot
of value i see the attainment side of
things isn't exactly how i feel i'm not
easy to put up with i i have a lot of
personality i'm from brooklyn i'm not
easy so we'll see if kai can handle the
heat that well according to the
production team you're completely easy
to work with they love netflix no forget
about the production team according to
the
uh to the to the complex the the
cleaning
freaking awesome stuff
major issue this is all gonna make sense
once my podcast takes off you're gonna
know what we're talking about you're
watching this listen we put the link
below a bunch of you guys have already
subscribed go subscribe this clip is
going to be on twitter we're going to
put it all over the place wednesday put
it in your calendar what time is it by
the way do we know the time it's 1 p.m
wednesday at 1 00 pm put in your
calendar wednesday 1 p.m eastern
standard time that's 10 a.m pacific put
it in your calendar next wednesday
jedidiah bill alive uh share this uh
content today as well to understand the
perspective of what jedidiah is going to
be doing because the moment people see
how jedediah nikki fried had the
wonderful conversation today more people
are going to want to tune in to this
podcast supposed to continue anyways
having said that thank you so much we're
excited about you being part of the team
that's it we're done
have a great weekend everybody tuesday
saturday by the way no podcast for us
for nine days i'm not doing podcast next
week so i'll be out for nine days and
i'll start afterwards but jedi will be
on next week so will you take everyone
have a great weekend bye-bye